good evening and welcome to the national
Churchill Library and center my name is
Michael Bishop and I am director of the
library an executive director of the
international Churchill Society the
result of a collaboration between the
Society and the George Washington
University the library is the first
research facility in the nation's
capital devoted to the study of Winston
Churchill here students and visitors
have access to a vast range of primary
and secondary materials an interactive
touchscreen exhibit and soon displays of
original manuscripts and artifacts and
let me take this opportunity to
encourage you to join the International
Churchill Society by visiting our
website ww-when stan churchill org the
benefits of membership are many and
include a subscription to our quarterly
publication of Churchill Scholarship
finest hour
a few programming notes before turning
to the subject of the evening I hope
that you'll return to the national
Churchill librarian Center on March 1st
when Elliot Cohen will discuss his new
book the big stick the limits of soft
power and the necessity of military
force and on April 26 we will welcome
former British Foreign Secretary David
Owen now Lord Owen who will speak about
his new book cabinets finest hour
the hidden agenda of May 1940 Churchill
is broadly acclaimed as the greatest
leader of the 20th century and in our
programming at the library we will not
only explore his life in career but the
very nature of leadership itself and
just as Churchill bestowed the last
century like a colossus so abraham
lincoln.the strode the 19th
the two men were very different one was
born in a palace and the other in a log
cabin one had sybaritic tastes while the
other was ascetic
but each was marked by both magnanimity
and a magnificent sense of humor
qualities that may be late
perhaps the ability to see the humor in
things makes one more likely to forgive
the foibles of others examples of
Churchill's humor and wit abound often
related to his famed but sometimes
exaggerated fondness for alcohol when
warmed by warned by a temperance
campaigner that strong drink rages and
stingeth like a serpent Churchill
replied I've been looking for a drink
like that all my life on another
occasion when leaving the House of
Commons Churchill was scolded by a
female MP who declared Winston you are
drunk
he replied yes and you are ugly but
tomorrow I shall be sober Lincoln's
humor tended more towards self
deprecation he related the tale of an
encounter he had with a woman in a small
town who looked at him and exclaimed why
I do believe you are the ugliest man I
ever saw Lincoln apologized for civil
fronting the woman but then asked her
what she would like him to do about it
she thought for a moment and replied
well you might stay home during one of
the famed lincoln-douglas debates in
Illinois a spectator shouted that
Lincoln was being two-faced two-faced
cried Lincoln if I had two faces do you
think I'd wear this one
Lincoln's humor was an essential
component of his personality and
political persona but tonight our guest
will explore whether his humor might
occasionally have been a handicap
Richard Carradine was educated at Corpus
Christi and Queens colleges Oxford and
at the University of California at
Berkeley for three decades he taught
history at the University of Sheffield
before being appointed Rhodes professor
of American history and institutions at
Oxford University
and a fellow of st. Catharines College
he was elected president of Corpus
Christi College Oxford in 2010 and
served in that exalted host until his
retirement last year he is the author of
one of the finest modern biographies of
the 16th President Lincoln a life of
purpose and power which was awarded the
Lincoln Prize in 2007 and he has also
written the upcoming Lincoln's sense of
humor on which tonight's lecture is
based this year marks the 500th
anniversary of Corpus Christi an
occasion being marked in many ways
including a magnificent new exhibition
featuring the college's manuscript
treasures that just opened at the Folger
Shakespeare Library on Capitol Hill and
I encourage you all to visit it ladies
and gentlemen
Professor Richard coyote well thank you
very much for that that warm welcome
Michael among the arresting displays at
the Chicago Sanitary Fair in 1864 was an
exhibit labeled the two American
humorists one of the two and one of the
two busts was that of Dan Rice the black
face minstrel as you see him in 1859 the
original humorist as he appeared in his
great Union speech before the medical
students in Philadelphia I don't know
what he was lecturing on but they we had
no record of how much benefit the
medical students took from this talk the
other bus was of Abraham Lincoln and few
would have corraled with the description
of Lincoln as the American humorist
/ Lincoln was a mold breaker the first
president consistently to make
storytelling and laughter tools of the
office
no occupant of the White House since her
since matched his talent in this respect
not least because a reputation but too
much popularity has been deemed
politically damaging Franklin
Roosevelt's lightheartedness was judged
even by his admirers to be undignified
John F Kennedy one of the most amusing
men to hold the highest office and
widely admired as a humorist
still held back in press conferences for
fear of appearing and statesmen like
even Ronald Reagan who came closest to
Lincoln in his skill as a raconteur and
his readiness to make himself the butt
of a joke was open to the charge that
his humor was a substitute for thought
and since he was willing to do anything
for a laugh risk becoming a board
affordable routine Lincoln by contrast
suffered few such inhibitions humor was
central to Lincoln's being and in this
talk I'll analyze what made him laugh
and the purposes and uses to which he
put his jokes and stories and in
considering the political consequences
I should indicate as my title suggests
that the story is not solely positive
Lincoln sense of humor was unusually
capacious he wrote relished almost every
form of the comic at one end of the
spectrum
he drew pleasure from tall tales from
absurdity and larger-than-life
characters at the other he took cerebral
pleasure in the plasticity ambiguity and
surprises of language there's no simple
taxonomy of Lincoln's humor but between
these two poles of enjoyment he
appreciated a variety of other forms and
happily indulged in quick wit irony
logical fallacy satire and notoriously
dirty jokes and stories
not least like many successful and
effective humorists he knew as Michaels
just explained he knew how to win over
an audience by laughing at himself and
so it's beginning with a few more
examples of this habit of self mockery
but for Lincoln possessed a very strong
sense of self-worth and as a result he
was able to take a joke at his own
expense joining in the jollity with the
utmost innocence and good nature he made
much of his unprepossessing appearance
conscious of his very unusual physical
proportions his height and particularly
his unusually long limbs his long legs
and very long arms and aware that many
considered him an ugly man and he faced
that head-on casting himself as the
subject of the story he related an
encounter with a stranger in a railroad
car who said excuse me sir but I have an
article in my possession which belongs
to you taking a jack knife from his
pocket to the man explained this was
placed in my hand some years ago with
the injunction that I was to keep it
until I found a man uglier than myself
allow me now to say so I think you are
fairly entitled to the property
Lincoln's jesting also gave rise to a
yarn that he was splitting rails he
found himself looking down the gun
barrel of a passerby who explained that
they correct he had promised to shoot
the first man he met who was uglier than
himself
getting a good look at the man's face
Lincoln remarked having bared his chest
if I am uglier than you then blaze away
[Music]
Lincoln loved the absurd and he loved
tall tales
according to Noah Brooks he thought that
the chief characteristic of American
humor was its grotesqueness and
extravagance
he loved the story of Bill the village
drunkard there are a lot of drunks in
Lincoln's stories a drunk who got
catastrophic ly intoxicated on a day of
heavy rain staggered down an alley and
fell asleep in a bed of mud waking as it
was getting dark
he thought he sought out the public pump
to wash himself on his way he met
another drunk leaning over a horse post
which bill mistook for the pump and at
once took hold of the arm of this man of
a handle the use of which said the
occupant of the post to throwing up bill
put both his hands under and gave
himself a thorough washing and made his
way to the grocery as he entered one of
his comrades horrified by the sight
explained why bill what in the world is
the matter my god he replied you oughta
have seen me before I was washed there
may be no surprise that Lincoln
celebrated for the craftsmanship economy
energy and idiomatic color his prose
should have loved the humorous
possibilities and curiosities of the
English language
he discovered particular usages he
enjoyed discovering particularly usages
and the meanings of words he smiled at Z
as he put it the Dutchman's expression
of somebody tying his dog loose
he took delight in in tons he smilingly
told the busy operators in the telegraph
office that since it was a fast day he
was pleased to see them working so fast
he memorized the phrase of the satirist
Augustine dugong Endymion Hurst whose
head and liked his books is read
in court proceedings Lincoln knew how to
use a pun to advantage an opposing
lawyer who claimed that he could bring a
man to prove a live at Kapoor Vinod an
alibi heard Lincoln shooting back I have
no doubt you can bring a man to prove a
lie by puns of course are designed to
elicit groans and this may well have
been Lincoln saying when he said to
Seward and me Seward as they were
passing the sign in Washington for T are
strong ah
Lincoln T are strong but coffee are
stronger if it is a groan as an event
represents now as a as a self-taught
Euclidean Lincoln to particular pleasure
in the misapplication or subversion of
logic he relished the story of John
Moore an Illinois state treasurer who
was returning home one night inebriated
in a cast drawn by a fine pair of red
steers as they passed through a grove
one of the cards wheels struck a stump
and threw the pole out of the ring of
the yoke the freed steers ran away
leaving more sound asleep early in the
morning he aroused himself when looking
over the side of the cart and around in
the woods he said if my name is John
Moore I've lost a pair of steers with my
name 8 John Moore I found a cart and in
similar vein Lincoln told of attending a
meeting at the Illinois lunatic asylum
it was a chilly building and Lincoln or
a hat as he made his way along a little
lunatic darted out from a door and
exclaimed sir I am amazed that you
should presume to wear your hat in the
presence of Christopher Columbus
Oh Mike beg your pardon mr. Columbus
Lincoln replied removing his hat and
walked on later after the meeting and
with his hat back on his head Lincoln
once more met the little man who
severely reproached him Sir I am
astounded that you should dare to wear
your hat in
presence of General Washington pray
excuse me general said Lincoln taking
off his hat I seems to me that less than
an hour ago you said you were
Christopher Columbus oh yes that is
quite correct but that was by another
mother like Lincoln Lincoln is alleged
to have said wit laughs at everybody and
humor laughs with everybody and that
because of that I think it's fair to say
that wit was sharp wit was not his most
representative mode of humor but Noah
Britt Noah Brooks was far too sweeping
when he said that Lincoln was not witty
but brim full of humor the truth was
that Lincoln had a capacity for
devastatingly quick quick wit and
trenchant repartee when it was observed
that Attorney General Edward Bates had
black hair and a white beard Lincoln
thought it could hardly be otherwise he
uses his jaws more than he does his
brain and one day a delegation called on
Lincoln is a shortly after Lincoln takes
office in 1861 and when he's bombarded
by office seekers a delegation called to
urge the appointment of the friend of
heirs to the post of the Commissioner of
the Sandburg Island Hawaii and they
emphasize not only his fitness for the
post but his poor health which they said
would benefit from the balmy climate of
Hawaii the president's closed the
interview with affected regret gentlemen
I'm sorry to say that there are eight
other applicants for that place and they
are all sicker than your man
Lincoln enjoyed the dry the ironic on
the oblique wit that he heard in others
this was the case for instance with the
farmer who protested banging I ain't
greedy about land I only just want what
joins mine he used dry wit to deflate
arrogance to a young German nobleman who
desiring and military appointment made
much of his distinguished lineage and
who made much of his distinguished
lineage Lincoln said well that need not
trouble you that will not be in your way
if you behave yourself as a sodium and
more gentle was the formula that you
used more than once when exceeding to a
request for a job the lady there of this
says she has two sons who want to work
set them at it if possible
wanting to work is so rare and merit
that it should be encouraged now many
and that as most of the stories of
Lincoln told as acquaintances put it
politely would not do exactly for the
drawing-room at the vulgar and the
earthy were a mainstay of his humor we
marked upon by his family his friends
and his colleagues a Lincoln himself
when asked why do you not write out your
stories and put them in a book a dream
self up fixed his face as if a thousand
dead carcasses and a million of privies
were shooting all their stench into his
nostrils and said such a book would
stink like a thousand pretties the
several colleagues later emphasized it
was not the crudity that Lincoln loved
so much as the stories pertinence and
wit and this was probably true and we
should remember that Lincoln's immodest
stories were more offensive to Victorian
sensibilities than two hours so surely
true of the tale he told to John Palmer
uh sure
a collector of relics heard about an old
lady with a dress she had worn during
the Revolutionary War he visited her and
asked if she would produce the dress to
satisfy his love of aged things she did
so and he enthusiastically how did not
saying were you the rare
this lady once young and blooming war in
the time of Washington no doubt when she
came home from the dressmaker's she
kissed you as I do now
and as he did so heartily the
unimpressed owner remarked stranger if
you want to kiss something all you'd
better kiss my ass it's sixteen years
old of Madras and Lincoln used in you
endo too to jest about Anatomy and
sexual relations but persistently asked
by Kate chase the daughter of salmon P
chase who had seen him standing next to
a wall up in an alley what he had been
doing he caved in and said well to tell
the truth miss chase I went up that
alley to shake hands with a fellow I
used to know who stood up for me at my
wedding
and when Mary Lincoln attired in an
evening gown had her cut to disease
taken by Matthew Brady in New York the
studio copies were stamped on the back
entered by act of Congress she sent one
to her husband who opened the letter
considered the photograph and the
inscription remarked that's a lie she
never was entered by act of Congress
Lincoln took great pleasure in Saturn
the young man he engaged in occasionally
reckless personal attacks through
anonymous or pseudonymous Lampoon's in
particular the lost townships and
ill-judged assault on James Shields
state state conference and now what was
his position was in hella state office
which led to a duel which was aborted
only at the last minute and after that
Lincoln exercised much more control as a
satirist in private amongst his lawyer
friends he would occasionally impale an
object to disagreeable to him on a
sarcastic glance and he lost none of his
appetite for reading the satirical
masterpieces of others including the
Opium soliloquy of Shakespeare's Richard
the third or the genius of David Ross
Locke's assault on Copperhead ISM
through his grotesque creation petroleum
of the naseby but the prevailing tone of
the humor that passed Lincoln's
her lips lacked cruelty and malice and
his satirical for us were in the main
restricted to carefully constructed
passages within longer speeches notably
in his contest with Douglas Stephen
Douglas in the 1850s several of those
Sally's repeat the Little Giant for
appealing to the racial antipathies of
white Illinois ons faced with the charge
that his opposition to slavery meant he
sought for the equality between the
races Lincoln mocked Douglass's
fallacious logic a chastened we declared
to cheers and laughter I do not
understand that because I do not want a
negro woman her slave
I must necessarily want her for a life I
will also add that I have never had the
least apprehension but I all my friends
would marry Negroes if there was no law
to keep them from it Lincoln this so my
plan for the range of Lincoln's humor
all of its utility Lincoln's
irrepressible sense of humor was so
central to his being and so frequently
deployed that it naturally prompts the
question what was its purpose in part it
provided aliens of empowerment of
imposing himself on others but it also
act as a health giving selves
quite simply Lincoln's appetite for
humor and his notorious vulnerability to
depression with two sides of the same
coin laughter was a therapeutic antidote
to the grievous low spirits to which she
was prone Lincoln himself explained if
it were not for these stories these
jokes these yes I should die they give
vent they are the vents of my moods and
gloom and he was evangelistic about the
reviving power of laughter at the
landmark cabinet meeting of the 22nd of
September 1862 where he unveiled the
preliminary Emancipation Proclamation
the president began by reading out a
short piece by Artemus Ward generally
said why don't you laughs colleagues
were irritated by his beginning of
meeting in this way why don't you laugh
with the fearful strain that is upon me
in night and day
if I did not laugh I should die but
there was a broader question what
political and public role did Lincoln's
humor play and here the picture is
complicated not least because purpose
and function intent and effect were not
necessarily one and the same Lincoln
used humor with deliberation deploying
it to secure particular outcomes in this
respect his levity has commonly been
regarded as a productive source of
strength but there were unintended
consequences too but in the hands of his
opponents Lincoln's reputation as a
humorist functioned as a weapon that
returned against him humor could be a
double-edged sword from an early age
Lincoln's comic story telling and
mimicry made him welcome and
entertaining company his odd lanky
appearance and bookish appetites night
in another young man had been a recipe
for social reticence and shyness but his
physical awkwardness seems not to have
troubled him rather he had a strong
sense as I said earlier of his self
worth and enjoyed the the personal
regard he won for his amiable wit and
quaint stories this social empowerment
helped inter alia to secure his election
as a military captain in the Black Hawk
War win him the respect of fellow
congressmen in his Washington
boardinghouse in the 1840s and make him
the magnet for the smiling attention of
liars and residents gathered at the
county seats of the Illinois 8th circuit
Lincoln relished the role of Entertainer
and was invigorated by it
during his debates in 1858 with Stephen
Douglas he actually grew stronger in
spirit and body over the course of the
campaign in contrast to his opponent he
didn't possess the actor's ease of
movement but he had a gift for squeezing
the most humor out of his material and
building to the climax of a story
particularly fond of James Hackett's
rendition of Falstaff he had the
confidence to advise the experienced
actor on how to deliver a line so as to
prompt the laugh the he Lincoln Lee was
later in life Lincoln would repeat with
appreciative Glee the description of a
type of southwestern orator who and I
quote mounted the rostrum threw back his
head shined his eyes opened his mouth
and left the consequences to God in
sharp contrast there was little in
Lincoln's own speeches that was not
planned and well calculated his use of
humor and stories in his public
addresses and private conversations was
really lacking in broader intent or
designed to cover up empty thought the
utility of this humor can be categorized
under six broad headings at times it lay
in crushing his opponents more commonly
and kindly when used as a means of
emphasizing his common touch and of
self-deprecation humor could be a weapon
of subtle attack on other occasions it
was a way of disingenuously planting a
self-serving idea into the mind of his
hearers it provided - a means of
tactical diversion or obfuscation and it
also had a role in relation to public
morale above all however he used his
stories as parables as appointed
accessible and persuasive form of
political explanation to begin with his
crushing of opponents as an aspiring
young politician Lincoln occasionally
resorted to cruel and aggressive humor
not simply to put his opponents on the
defensive but to eviscerate them to
humiliate them the roasting of Forker as
it was called was just one instance of
Lincoln using his power to hurt power
which he used to withering effect this
was during his campaign for re-election
to the state legislature in 1836 when he
spoke before a large crowd in
Springfield and his impressive speech it
prompted a request from George Walker a
prominent local Democrat that he should
be given the stand foger was a recent
convert from the Whig party and he'd
been rewarded and by his newer
associates with a lucrative public
office he'd also built the best house in
Springfield over which he directed a
lightning rod the only one in the place
15 years Lincoln's senior the
patronising porker declared that the
young man would have to be taken down
after waiting with suppressed excitement
Lincoln resumed the stand he
acknowledged he was young but his critic
should remember and I quote I am older
in years than I am in the tricks and
trades of politicians I desire to live
and I desire place and distinction but I
would rather die now than like the
gentlemen lived to see the day that I
would change my politics for an office
worth $3,000 a year and men feel
compelled to erect a lightning rod to
protect a guilty conscience from an
offended God now over time Lincoln learn
to be more deft and subtle in sharpening
his debating edge as a mature politician
he used gentler wits to put his
opponents on the backfoot no one was
more aware of this than Stephen Douglas
himself the little giant declared that
he did not fear Lincoln in debating
matters of substance but he confessed
there is one thing however which I stand
constantly in dread when Lincoln begins
to tell a story I begin to get
apprehensive every one of his stories
seems like a whack upon my back that is
that is exactly the effect that the
allegories and anecdotes of which he is
a master have upon me nothing else
disturbs me but when it begins to tell a
story I feel that I am about to be
overmatched in his face-to-face
engagement with the public Lincoln had
recourse to stories and jokes that would
remind his hearers of his lowly origins
or belonging to the backwoods and the
Prairie it encouraged common people to
see him as a natural man lacking
artifice able to engage with ordinary
farmers
with laborers on equal terms and his
lifelong identification with
self-identification with plain folk was
closely allied to his habit of
self-deprecation and now this amounted
to far more than a means of securing a
laugh by pre-empting comments about his
strange looks his modest upbringing and
cantillation eccentricities it was also
a means of enlisting the audience on the
side of the underdog
he used a sort of big man little man
technique he did it more or less
non-stop through his pre presidential
years not only against Forker as I just
indicated that against some of the
biggest oratorical beasts in the
Illinois democracy in his wrestling with
Douglas political wrestling with Douglas
in the 1850s assume he assumed the
identity of a modest provincial facing
the worldwide renown of the Democrats
prime hope for the White House who
enjoyed the status of a very great man
in Kazan was a very great man while he
himself Lincoln was only a small man
because the heavy irony of this language
intensified by the sight of the
diminutive Little Giant standing next to
the elongated Lincoln I mentioned the
idea of planting a self-serving idea
sometimes disingenuously
the National newspaperman who descended
on Illinois during 1858 to cover the
joint debates with Douglass including
Henry village of New York sheltering
together and error during a shouting
sort sheltering together one evening
during a thunderstorm Lincoln told the
young reporter that when he was clerking
in a country store his highest ambition
was to be a member of the state
legislature he continued with a chapel
since then of course I have grown some
but my friends have got me into this I
did not consider myself qualified for
the United States Senate now now to be
sure I I am convinced that I am good
enough for it but in spite of it all I
am staying to myself every day it is too
big a thing for you you will never get
it
Mary insists however that I am going to
be senator and prevalence of
United States - with his words he he's
followed with a roar of laughter with
his arms around his knees shaking all
over with mirth at his wife's ambition
just thank you explain such a sucker as
me as president Lincoln laughs but of
course its intent was utterly serious
observing the etiquette of modesty with
his rollicking laughter he cunningly
dropped into the mind of a Eastern
reporter the idea that he could be
ranked for the presidency Lincoln's
humor also provided a means of diversion
one of his associates judged that in the
courtroom
Lincoln mostly resorted to stories to
shore up to stiffen a faltering case he
never indulged in fun when he had a
great case one which he believed was
right but in this case with it were weak
he would tell stories cover his opponent
the witness etcetera would ridicule keep
caught injury shrieking with laughter in
the political sphere he used anecdotes
to turn redirect deflect or smooth a
conversation without giving offence he
recognized the sharpness of a refusal or
rebuke may be blunted by an appropriate
story his secretary John Hay told how
late in 1863 an infernal nuisance of a
Brooklyn postmaster with his eyes on the
following year's presidential election
and wondering if Lincoln was going to
run again fastened himself and I quote
fastened himself to the tycoon's
president and tried to get into
conversation on the subject of the
succession Lincoln quickly put him off
with a story of his friend Jesse Dubois
who a state auditor controlled the use
of the Illinois State House in
Springfield and itinerant quack preacher
requested a venue for our religious
lecture what's it about said Jesse the
second coming of Christ said the parson
nonsense roar and growl Jesse if Christ
had been a Springfield once and got away
be damned clearer coming again
above all else
however Lincoln's stories served as a
colorful means of instruction and
elucidation he told Chauncey Depew they
say I tell a great many stories I reckon
I do but I have found in the course of a
long experience that common people
common people take them as they run are
more easily influenced and informed with
a medium a broad illustration than in
any other way so Lincoln uses stories as
parables and and in the courtroom he
used opposite tales to win the
confidence of juries lacking in formal
education exposing the false logic of an
opposing counsel he said he was reminded
of the Cooper who having trouble in
closing up a barrel put a boy in sight
to hold the head in place the plan
worked so well that the Cooper drove on
the hoops and finished the job
forgetting all about the boy or how he
was to be gotten out the story's and
striking images gave Lincoln the means
of driving home political arguments with
engaging economy when John Pope
telegraphed Washington that he had
captured five thousands of Beauregard's
men and was marching on the Confederates
and on the morrow would have the rebels
in his part the cabinet asked the
president that his opinion I reminds me
Lincoln has always reminded of a story
that reminds me
he replied of an an old woman in
Sangamon County who was ill the doctor
came and prescribed prescribed some
medicine for her constipation returning
the next morning he found her fresh and
well and getting breakfast asked if the
medicine had worked she confirmed that
it had how many bowel movements
physician inquired 142 she replied madam
madam I am serious the position replied
I know you are joking how many 142 madam
I must know you couldn't have had 104 it
is necessary for me to have the exact
number of movement I tell you 140 to 140
mm wind
the story told Lincoln added simply I'm
afraid Pope's captures are a hundred and
forty of them winds that closed the
cabinet discussion during a critical
phase of the Trent affair and recording
the Trent affair brezin had threatened
war following the Union Navy seizure of
two Confederate envoy and dollars from
the brief ship during critical phase of
this affair Lincoln found himself with
the support of only one member of the
cabinet and said it reminded him to the
drunk who had strayed into an Illinois
church and fell asleep in the front row
he slumbered on as the revivalist asked
who are on the Lord's side and the
congregation responded by rising on mass
when the preacher then inquired who are
on the devil side the sleeper stirred
but not fully grasping the inquiry and
seeing the minister on his feet he stood
up I don't exactly understand the
question he said but I'll stand by you
person to the last but it's it but it
seems to me that we're in our hopeless
minority now Lincoln supporters seized
on his studied use of humor to show how
an occupant of the White House could
remain a genial man of the people at the
president placed the ordeal of wartime
office his supporters world is in better
at habit of telling ludicrous stories
into a larger appreciation of his moral
character Pro administration newspapers
readily drew attention to the
president's latest story
Lincoln's private secretary John Hay
cultivated a warm relationship with
several journalists and supplied them
with examples of the president's wit
linked as humor helped cast him as the
representative American the ladies the
women's rights activist Caroline Ely
door reboot rebuked those fine ladies of
the woman's loyal league who were
repelled by the president's homeland
honors and jokes as a nation she wrote
we are an intelligent but not of
cultivated people mr. Lincoln fairly
represents our average
Mainland and he has never written a
letter that the humble of his
constituents can understand our design
master knew a little at the classic
Laura knew little of classic law
historic legend but he did know how to
tell a simple instructive story
commercial interests exploited this
benign reading of Lincoln's humor in
compilations of jokes and stories
supposedly but rarely originating with
the president the publishers of old Abes
Joker or witch at the White House asked
what could be more natural than to
associate with quips and pranks and
wanton wiles the name of one who so
greatly enjoys and successfully
perpetuates the fine old full-flavored
joke graphic advertisements for old aids
jokes or wigs at the Royal fresh from
Abraham's bosom comprising all his
issues accepting the greenbacks showed
the bearded Railsplitter
entertaining a racked audience of
smiling common folk the only authentic
life of Abraham Lincoln captured him in
his recognizable storytelling posture
with his hand router's me and for
drawing up his knee to his face it was
in this spirit of appreciation that in
February 1864 william cullen bryant
radical New York Evening Post offered a
commentary on a wide array of Lincoln's
jokes and little stories its intention
was to show how these were the mark of a
purposeful genial and wise
commander-in-chief an early contribution
to the presidential campaign the column
aimed to reveal how the tortured mind of
a suburb of a suffering bone weary and
patient president found occasional
relief in an appropriate anecdote or
well turned jest his atrocious puns
brought him innocent delight but Bryant
explained in addition to their
therapeutic value stories and wit served
as a means of rebuke to those who wasted
his time with trivial requests beneath
his Liberty lay a stratum of ethical
rock
now in setting out the value and
benefits of Lincoln's storytelling his
supporters were responding to his
opponents disdain for a chief magistrate
whose taste in jokes made him unfit for
his position democrats had already
berated lincoln for his smutty jokes
during the senatorial campaign of 1858
and from the moment of this presidential
nomination in May 1861 presses ridiculed
a candidate of whom nothing favorable
could be said except that and I quote he
once drove oxen went barefooted split
rails is a possibly good lawyer tells a
smutty story in good style and is the
ugliest man in the West during the
crisis of winter of 1860 61 the
president-elect determined jocularity
provided much ammunition for those keen
to deem him politically out of his depth
Harper's Weekly on the eve of his
inauguration presented our presidential
Mary man holding a drained glass in his
in his hand while engaged in a lively
exchange of wit and humor with a set of
rough inebriated companions as a funeral
Hearst marking the death of the Union
passes by you could see through the
window throughout the four years of the
war both Confederates and critics in the
Union see zomling consumer as a stick
with which to beat him with the war
taking its early toll in the summer of
1861 an embittered Confederate
sympathizer out of that Volk drew
Lincoln as a gesture in the comedy of
death sharing the stage with an array of
toy soldiers resembling billions High
Command their common charge was that the
president's appetite below jokes exposed
a disabling lack of gravitas and
principle that he used humor to mask his
deficiencies his jokes measured his
cruel disregard for the victims of war
Lincoln the heartless buffoon became a
recurrent theme opposition presses were
quick to circulate the essence of a
powerful Harper's Weekly cartoon
Columbia confronts her children
published shortly after the grievous
union losses at Fredericksburg here you
can see a female figure with her arm
outstretched
Columbia pointing at Lincoln standing
outside the War Department between Edwin
Stanton and Joseph Hooker and asking
where are my 15,000 sons murdered at
Fredericksburg Lincoln's callous answer
this reminds me of a little joke
prompting outraged interruption go tell
your joke at Springfield another cartoon
cast him as manager Lincoln the sole
figure on an empty stage he is an
ingratiating hand-wringing but smiling
impresario with a pistol sword and the
other debris of a routed army at his
feet ladies and gentlemen he announces I
regret to say that the tragedy entitled
the Army of the Potomac has been
withdrawn and I have substituted three
new and striking classes or Burrell asks
a further common accusation at odds with
Lincoln Lee Inc a total buffoon was
Lincoln the fanatic who indulged a love
of sadistic and quixotic humor through
savage and dictatorial policies these
were cruel and unfunny jokes played by a
tyrant who took pleasure in his
disregard for the Constitution
emancipation the suspension of habeas
corpus the draft black troops
reconstruction military rule and the
policies associated with the prosecution
of a hard war were evidence of this
warped sense of humor disgusted by the
president's racial policies Chauncey
burr the Copperhead told him to quote
crack your low jokes massive Lincoln
only white men to really not hold so put
your foot down mater Lincoln and
trampled them out of the world return to
the campaign of 1864 the the voices of
complaint about the National Joker in
the White House became
vehement chorus of condemnation during
that re-election year the themes of the
argument didn't alter but anti
administration presses and opposition
political platforms asserted them with
more aggression and imaginative color
than ever the election contest was
explicitly joined in the opening weeks
of the year
Bryant's positive appreciation of
Lincoln's humor as I mentioned a moment
moments ago in the pages of the Evening
Post drew from James Gordon Bennett New
York Herald the headline the
presidential campaign the first
electioneering document in just about a
portion of it here the claim that it was
the first election excellent document
was teasing and disingenuous Bryant
though lukewarm about the presidents
Rhee nomination had been responding to
an assault on Lincoln the smutty Joker
already launched in the pages of The
Herald with moves afoot amongst
Republicans to deliver the party's
nomination to John C Fremont Bennett ran
a long article Fremont general framework
takes the presidential field not a
smutty Joker setting out the generals
claims as a military leader and
Emancipator the herald followed each
positive statement in this article with
the board refrain repeated 30 times over
Fremont is not a smutty Joker the
Maverick Bennett wanted the party to
choose the general or some other
candidate and thus astonish all Europe
overall the rebellion and prevent us
from having a smutty Joker for our next
president in the the funniest of fun and
Harper's Weekly the radical cartoonist
Frank Bello cast Lincoln as the National
Joker a circus jester who was reminded
of a little joke and another little
story in one he stands grinning under
three wartime scenes this one here
and the three wartime scenes the
hospital the battlefield and Liberty
consumed by flames
each pointing the good test contrast
between an
residential levity and Marshall horror
[Music]
setting the tone for the peace Democrats
are sort on Lincoln was the striking
front cover of Andrew adder UPS Lincoln
Jana there is a a clear a typo Lincoln
on about Lincoln Jana or humors of uncle
Abe the second Joe Miller published by
the ratted copperhead jf fix the order
or the pseudonym adder up was a week
joke
add her up for copperhead action hand
Lincoln the lover of the English joke
Smith Joe Miller drives a wedge labeled
joke into a log that is splitting into
North and South the rail splitter and
the side splitter here becomes the union
splitter Democrats insinuated a critique
of Lincoln the Joker into each of their
key campaigning themes of 1864 the
administration's perverted racial
radicalism its tyrannical assault on
civil liberties and it's generally
demoralizing influence none was more
challenging than the charge of Lincoln's
shocking liberty in the face of the
summers numbing military slaughter the
Chicago times never slows a manufacturer
story attributed grants bloody campaign
in Virginia to a White House Conclave
the bottle went freely round mr. Lincoln
was in his best vein and anecdote and
smutty joke followed each other in quick
succession the theme of Lincoln the
Widowmaker who lays the nation across
his knee and tickles her catastrophe
with obscene jokes and little stories
became a Democrat campaign staple
nothing gave the attack greater power
than the accusation that when visiting
the Bloods drenched and Teton
battlefield in October 1862 Lincoln had
shattered it's sanctity by asking to
hear a vulgar comic song while touring
the field according to the New York
world the incident took place soon after
the fight with bodies yet warm in their
graves accompanied by Marshall Ward Hill
lemon
George McClellan and another officer
Lincoln drove over the field as heavy
details of men were burying the dead as
they neared the old stone bridge where
the bodies were piled highest Lincoln
suddenly slapping Marshall lamin upon
the knee explained come lemon give us
that song about Picayune Butler
McClellan has never heard it with a
shudder the general protested not now if
you please Marshall I would prefer to
hear it some other place and time now
the story of sealed various forms few
accounts failed to emphasize Lincoln's
vulgar taste for a Negro song a popular
African American banjo song often
performed by blackface minstrels
tickle even Butler's coming to town
confirmed his perverted racial appetites
Democrats hammered the message in music
and graphics satire as described in the
the crude rhymes of the Democratic
National Campaign songster Abe may crack
his jolly jokes or bloody feels of
stricken battle while yet the eddying
life tide smokes from men that die like
butchered cattle yet a he a yet the guns
grow cold to pimps and pets may crack
his stories your name is of the grander
mold and linked with all our brightest
glories the 1864 campaign gave political
cartoonists unbridled opportunity to
exploit the familiar theme of Lincoln's
compulsive jesting in Joseph Baker's
lithograph kampala Columbia demands her
children so I just got back one looks
like too much too much there we go
Columbia demands her children an angry
Columbia points to a discomforted
president and shouts mr. Lincoln give me
back my fifty thousand sons which
elicits a feeble diversionary response
well the fact is by the way that that
reminds me of a story
a Currier and Ives cartoon running the
Machine as Lincoln laughing uproariously
at his own jokes while the new secretary
of the Treasury William Pitt fastened
turns out greenbacks after McClellan's
nomination a JH colored cartoon
characterized the Democrats nominated
Democratic candidate as Hamlet
contemplating Lincoln's laughing head on
the palm of his hand and saying to
governor Horatio Seymour I knew him
Horatio a fellow of Infinite Jest where
be your jibes now the two depictions of
the gleeful president were more
arresting however than the sinister
portrayal by Matt Morgan in the British
magazine fun Columbia's nightmare
inspired by Henry versus the nightmare
the cartoon shows Lincoln as a smirking
Semitic demon seated on the terrified
recumbent Maiden above all the Antietam
episode offered the best target of
graphic attack especially potent was a
poorly executed but still arresting car
two-headed the commander-in-chief
conciliate the soldiers vote on the
battlefield
it plays Lincoln at the center clad in a
long cloak and holding a tartan cap a
reminder of the cowards disguise he was
said to have worn when cutting short his
journey to Washington as president-elect
several dead bodies are being carried
from the field while an officer
evidently McClellan tends to a wounded
soldier a distraught figure his back to
the viewer signals his distress by
holding a hand to his eyes he
remonstrate as the president demands now
marshal the singers Picayune Butler or
something else that's funny
Lincoln loyalists took alarm at the grip
of this bogus story on the public
imagination lanlan prepared a reply for
the press and Lincoln considered
considerate for a while thought it was
too bellicose and offered to try his own
hand at it in a careful statement
designed to appear over lamb in the
signature Lincoln rebutted the false
accounts while travelling on an
ambulance from Antietam to general
Porter's call Lincoln wrote the
president asked me to sing a sad little
song 20 years ago which he'd often heard
me sing then some one of the party I do
not think it was the president asked me
to sing something else and I sang two or
three little comic songs of which picker
you and Butler was one however the place
was not the battlefield the time was 16
days after the battle no dead body was
seen during the whole time nor even a
grave that had not been rained on since
he was made neither
general McClellan or anywhere else made
any objection to the singing on
reflection however Lincoln decided not
to release his account telling lemon you
know he'll this is the truth and the
whole truth about the affair but I just
like to appear as an apologist from an
act of my own which I know was right the
Democrats are sought on Lincoln's
obscenity vulgarity and levity during
the dark summer of 1864 did nothing to
improve the president's re-election
prospects but as the political weather
changed during early September and
confidence in Lincoln's reelection grew
wore Democrats joined Republicans in
rebutting Copperhead colonies David s
Coddington explained that the Chicago
Convention has left a Democrat no choice
between Jefferson Davis with all his
crimes and Abraham Lincoln with all his
faults call Abraham Lincoln a joker why
the Chicago party the Democrats are
trying to make this war the ghastliest
joke of the continent or century elect
that ticket he said and you elect a
laugh at your own arrogance imbecility
and cowardice and in keeping with the
change mood
poster cartoons the similar sympathetic
to the National Union Party turned the
joke against the Democratic nominee
McClellan tries to ride two horses
played on the eklund metaphor that
Lincoln had put into play with his story
of an old Dutch farmer who remarked to a
companion that it was not best to swap
horses when crossing streams in this
cartoon little Mack appears as a
star-spangled circus rider struggling to
keep a foot on each horse the president
looks on clad in clowns motley but
unsmiling
and serious McClellan has one hand
pulling on the reins of a war charger
straining for action and is tugged in
the other direction by a horse labeled
peace he curses them saying I can't
manage the act know how Lincoln sharp
words you try to ride them two horses on
the peninsula for two years Mack but it
wouldn't work drew attention to the deep
division between McClellan and the peace
wing of his party more demeaning still
was a Harper's Weekly cartoon of the
little Napoleon as a diminutive
plaything standing on the palm of
Lincoln's cupped hand seated at his desk
the president addresses the tiny general
and turns the laugh against his opponent
this reminds me of a little joke it's
impossible to determine precisely how
Lincoln's reputation as a Joker shaped
the political balance sheet in 1864 that
the administration's supporters included
many who found the President for levity
distasteful indicates that for them at
least the matter was not decisive but
his opponents clearly believed it
offered great electoral opportunity
there focus on the cruel and smutty
Joker during the final weeks of the
campaign should not be seen simply as a
measure of increasing desperation since
they are relish for the issue had been
evident well before their hope I'm
Lincoln too well understood how his
reputation for levity could expose him
to misrepresentation and electoral
damage was only after careful reflection
that he opted not to respond publicly to
the bogus Antietam story in time after
his death his reputation as the peerless
presidential story spinner joke teller
and ready wit would come to take on a
character hold it positive and benign
that however was not the reality
during the dark and deadly days of war
[Applause]
two quick announcements we have time for
just a couple of questions if you'd like
to ask one please come to the microphone
here and also we have copies of
Richard's Lincoln prize award-winning
biography Lincoln life is purpose and
power available on the table over there
I'll buy one hello
out of all the Lincoln jokes by him or
about him what's your favorite there
there are there's too many but I say
it's a question I'm often asked and it's
when I have thought about so thank you
for asking it I spent most of my
academic career studying American
popular religion in this period so I've
particularly attracted to Lincoln's use
of the the meeting house and the
relationship between preacher and
congregation as a source of his humor
and the one I told about the the the
drunk who says I'll stand with you
Minister that I I think we're in a
hopeless minority is what one one of my
favorites so there are several of that
genre that I like and I think one that I
find particularly attractive because
it's so deft and so gentle and so I
chose Lincoln so quick on his feet is
the story of Lincoln in the hospital
where there is a young woman at the
bedside of the soldier who has been
wounded and she is very solicitous about
his about him and she asks he had to say
he's been shot through the testicles and
she asks where were you wanted and he
says I was wounded at Antietam
and she persists and Lincoln is aware of
what's going on and she turns to Lincoln
for son for some help so he talks to the
talks to the soldier privately and comes
back to the young lady says young lady
and the bullet that hit him would have
missed you
[Laughter]
I've long thought that Lincoln's skill
telling off-color jokes was the real
engine of his early career is that a
fair guess I think it I think it
probably is we well as I said we had to
be careful about what we mean by
off-color jokes and already today many
of them would not be seen to be quite so
crude as they were thought to be at this
ability in thought to be at the time a
number of his stories were collected
later by by Carl Sandburg and they're in
a in a with Kashyap I think an off-color
jokes in the Newberry Library I I think
his audience mostly his audiences were
male so when he was working as a young
man in New Salem when he was on the
stump
when certainly when he was a lawyer
meeting with other lawyers and the
people of locality in the hotels as the
the court festivals as the in the Eighth
Circuit her as they tour around these
would have been all-male companies and I
pretty confident that in those settings
a lot of these lots of the stories would
have been a combination of scatological
and and sexual I think Lincoln was right
when he said that was cumulative either
like a thousand stinking privies in the
census I think that what the weight of
his humor weight of the storytelling in
those early years at least would have
been of this kind but and that he did
not like dirty stories for their own
sake and has to be has to be said maybe
in those storage heading competitions in
the hotels were the others just other
other liars that might have been the
case but for Lincoln what really gave
and this is what his friend said of him
and what really gave the stories and
their attraction to Lincoln
pertinence they're capacitive it was the
wit and their applicability to a
particular setting settler and yes he
was a smutty Joker but there was a
purpose to that word what was yours over
your source materials because you know
so much of the history of Lincoln was
pieced together or many many years later
from interviews of people that had known
him many years later and much is sort of
apocryphal we invented and so in terms
of all of the other things how reliable
is this much humor that you're archana
that's a very good question and of
course there's always that real tension
between wanting to claim authenticity
for the really good joke and but this is
if there's two ways of answering that
question one is that actually there's a
very good compendium of Lincoln stories
by Paul's outs in fact two compendium
who serious scholar of Lincoln's
humor did it really write about in the
way in which I have done it's rather
more so the encyclopedic and a listing
of the stories there were the stories
that we know that Lincoln told because
there in his own hand or they have
reported in his own speeches there are
the stories that his immediate
contemporaries John those who worked
with him and wrote down at the time and
reported at the time then there are
those that are told after his death by
those who are close to Lincoln and then
you get more remote from that from the
front from the scriptural authority as
it were and into the early 20th century
where you get people talking about
stories they heard of their parents so
they're far but hurdling can tell and
you have to question the authenticity of
those they're quite a number of those
memoirs of Lincoln's contemporaries
political contemporaries and legal
contemporaries published through the
1870s 80s and 90s and are a source which
of course one uses with discretion
William Herndon you may be aware after
Lincoln's death was so appalled by the
things or being it claimed about Lincoln
particularly in respected his religion
that he set about accumulating material
from those who had known Lincoln in
Indiana and in Illinois and most of
these reminiscences are stopped in 1860
but we get a flavor from those as to
some of the ways in which Lincoln was
appreciated and as a humorous within it
was certainly several tales told by
people who were there at the time and I
think one can honor Connor honorably
take those as being authentic but you're
right there is this there is this issues
of the apocryphal and and wanting
certain Baris opening a one-story I
haven't told but inside it informally
afterwards which I had much admire I
might like and I I didn't know whether
to inclusion in the book or not in the
end I I did I'm not absolutely sick it's
too good to leave out but I'm not
absolutely certain that it can be proven
um could you give us a bit of the social
and cultural context about what was
considered smutty in that time period
and were there any gestures or phrases
that would be considered dirty or
something back then that we wouldn't
know about today any last name is a
sweater yes I'm sorry I ought to get no
dye and the answer is I think that the
the the material that would have been
considered vulgar smutty dirty would
have to do with sexual relations they'd
have to do with bodily functions he
knows the two main ones and I think you
know it in the sense you know so I mean
what is what has changed but I think
there were ways of alluding to it in the
in the mid 19th century more discreetly
alluding to it which would still have
been considered vulgar whereas I think
today we can make those support what
kind of reporters questions about five
or five years ago within
gallery art there was a albert durer
exhibit and he had the the description
of the paintings of whatever the gesture
and however the hands were being held
there was considered a dirty dirty
gesture back in our Thursday in the in
Germany and so I'm wondering if in the
1840s 50s 60s there was we use a middle
finger maybe they had some another
gesture made the same thing good
question i or question I don't I don't
know I got in heavy on staff thank you
thank you for coming
you mentioned Sandberg has a some source
of lincoln jokes or those uh within
dissolves dissol include those these
anchors you make I didn't I can't do
this all has Fela Sandberg's jokes with
involves no I got you I got those I was
directed to those and that kasha papers
which which Sandburg have used by
Michael Burlingame I believe most price
probably Michael is is such a generous
scholar and whenever he finds things
that you think that he thinks that his
fellow scholars would use so the
arresting to ring true oh yeah I think
so I mean I mean there's there's one
that some where David Lincoln tells this
the story of a man who is so trusting of
his wife that he bets that she will not
succumb to the overtures of another and
they becomes aware as he's standing
outside the door of their bedroom that
what is not as innocent as he thought he
was going to be and so he wraps on the
door and then the wife replies in a you
know in a in a rhyming
there's a rough Pulliam and Lincoln told
this to David Davis and two couple of
others and when this was while he was
president and he was Davis it alinka if
the public knew you were telling stories
like this it would just be the end so
when one knows that I think that that
from that from from that remark it it
has an author has authenticity some of
the others that are a report you just
think well and they sound plausible I
think I think that in a sense it doesn't
matter whether a particular joke is
authentic or not what we can be clear
about is that there is sufficient
authenticity in that spread of stories
for them to represent one of the styles
of humor that Lincoln indulged in but
there was occasion where he Lincoln got
very angry with some who came in Lincoln
was exhausted someone came in wants to
tell him a story and it was a filthy
story and then he just sent him out he
said that's terrible that man just
disgusts me and that's not funny
it has to have wit it has to be there
has to be a surprise there has to be a
point about it ya resent any idea it did
you thank you again very much
I remember recent references to locker
room talk which apparently a certain
person had a really hard time getting
over recently um is there any idea or
was there any female reaction to this
didn't women ever get to hear this or
Marilyn Taylor was there ever anything
like that maybe not I don't know
intrigues me yeah I don't know how many
of these jokes and Abraham shared with
married
getting yeah but I I take the analogy
that you're amazing and I would just
repeat what I said it I think in
Lincoln's case it was not it was not it
was not cruelty for its own sake and it
didn't it certainly didn't there's
nothing that suggests that Lincoln spoke
and in a way that demeaned women I think
almost all of the targets of his Hitler
are male and I have to think about about
that that they and the whether they're
preachers are whether they're drunks
were there but it's the foibles at the
foibles of humankind that he's wanting
to expose I agree with what Michael said
earlier that the sense of humor some
people with a sense of humor having an
appreciation the foibles of humankind
and that bringing up with it I think a
certain humility and well link it was
not a humble person and there is
humility I think in his relationships
with people so Lincoln was in no sense
of what you might call a conventional
locker room doesn't
[Applause]